de débuter merci monsieur le ministre la
parole et à monsieur sylvain verrions ce
pour les républicains
monsieur le premier ministre les bonnes
nouvelles sont rares pour les familles
depuis trois ans je vous rappelle
quelques unes de vos mesures aux effets
dévastateurs
la baisse du plafond du quotient
familial la modulation des allocations
familiales
le report du reversement la prime de
naissance la baisse des allocations en
2014 et 2015 ou encore le
raccourcissement du congé parental
la liste est longue vendredi soir vous
avez fait adopter un amendement au
projet de loi de finances rectificative
augmentant de 2 euros la réduction
forfaitaire de cotisations par heure
travaillée au bénéfice des particuliers
employeurs
reprenant ainsi une proposition que le
groupe les républicains avaient déposé
dans le cadre du projet de loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale et que
vous aviez à l'époque rejeté votre volte
face est une bonne nouvelle pour les
familles de france c'est une mesure
importante pour le secteur de l'emploi à
domicile qui se dégradent est de façon
très importante depuis que vous aviez
supprimer la déclaration au forfait en
néanmoins l'adoption de cette mesure en
catimini ne suffit pas à rassurer les
français n'iront ni à rendre clair votre
politique familiale les français
n'attendent pas de vous de la clarté de
la cohérence sur vos combinaisons
électorale avec vos ex allié ils
attendent de vous de la clarté de la
cohérence sur la politique économique
sur l'emploi sur la sécurité sur
l'immigration sur votre politique
fiscale et éviter de faire un cadeau
fiscal de quatre millions et demi à
mediapart
alors même que les artisans les français
coule sous l'impôt ou encore de la
clarté en matière de politique familiale
alors monsieur le premier ministre afin
d'être clair comptez-vous également
faire volte face sur le quotient
familial sur les allocations perçues
l'idée la parole et à la secrétaire
d'état chargée de la famille de
l'enfance et des personnes âgées de
l'autonomie madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député notre politique
familiale est clair et les cohérente
elle a d'abord été déterminée par une
exigence ramener la branche famille à l'
équilibre alors que nous avions trouvé
des comptes est extrêmement dégradée
notre deuxième notre deuxième volonté a
été de garantir la pérennité de la
branche famille c'est ce qui nous a
amenés d'une part à pratiquer
effectivement des économies mais à
choisir les vraies économies juste des
économies jusqu'à était d'une part la
modulation des allocations familiales
lors des zékré si vite et en fonction
des revenus des familles et les familles
effectivement dont les revenus sont
supérieurs à plus de 6000 euros par mois
et qui ont deux enfants ont vu leurs
allocations familiales réduite mais
cependant maintenu en respect du
principe de l'universalité des
prestations familiales et cette
politique là nous a permis de réorienter
nos z en faveur des familles les plus
démunies
d'abord les familles monoparentales qui
ont vu augmenter le complément sociale
les points les familles les premiers
soutiennent pour les familles ensuite
les familles de plus dans la pauvreté
et enfin elle nous permet de poursuivre
aujourd'hui une politique de
construction des lieux d'accueil pour
les jeunes enfants
et ce qui fait l'excellence et la
qualité de la politique familiale
française c'est cette capacité à
combiner taux d'activité professionnelle
des femmes élevées et taux de fécondité
élevée cette politique familiale
elle est juste elle est au plus près des
besoins des familles elle est moderne et
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
n'en changerons pas nous la confirmeront
et nous nous satisfaisons que vous nous
apportez votre soutien aujourd'hui en
faveur des mesures prises la semaine
dernière pour l'emploi familial
merci madame